Please
[Music]
First of all, please introduce yourself. Also,
could you please tell us about SMK and the name of the band? Yes,
who is that? Guitar Box. I'm Yurika Fuji, the bassist. It's Hitsuji Bungaku. What was the
history of the formation?
What was the story of the decisive battle?  I was invited to join, and
at first there were five of us, but
since we were high school students, we all formed
up when we were about 1516 years old,
but we all quit due to career choices, so
Fukuda joined first, and
Yurika joined in 2016, and we
never met like this.  I had never done it
before, but I saw other bands playing, so I
contacted them and started recruiting members,
and it became what it is now, so I
feel like I've been doing it for about 6 years, so that's the origin of the program.
When I was in junior high school, I just
randomly added that.
[Laughs]
If you were to
make another program with two random words instead of sheep literature, what would it be?I guess it would be because of
sheep and literature.I'd like it to be in
English or something, but I do
n't like it at all.
Sheep are good. They're
different from earth. They're
amazing because they're made of earth.
Me and my backpack have earthen
paper in them, and
cold
hair in them, so there's
no ginger fortune-telling.
What do you think?
Emergency elevators and emergency stairs, which are
common in noise bands.
[Laughs] It's an
emergency elevator. I heard that you
formed a band when you were students, but
how did the long time you spent together influence each other as band members and friends?  We've been
together for 6 years,
so we're
more like voice
actors and
brothers, so we're not really sure,
but we're very different.If we
went to this class, there would probably be three of us, so we're not in a
group, but we're different.  We
might not hang out in the same class that much,
but
that's why Manami is there. You
can do what you like, like yesterday. Well, I guess that's right.
Yuka-chan said I don't try hard, so I
thought, But I
learned something.  There's so much to learn.I'm pretty sure
I
'm the type of person who wouldn't do something if it meant doing something I didn't want to do would degrade the quality of what I wanted to do,
but those shorts are
amazing.  His way of thinking is
amazing, his sensitivity is
amazing, and I can feel it all the time, and I can
feel it extremely when it comes to one thing, so in that sense, it's
amazing.It's an
influence, or rather, I
respect it,
but thank you very much.Now on to the
next person,
Jujutsu Kaisen.
Congratulations on the release of the Shibuya Jihen tie-up song Morethe Wors.
Thank you. The harmonies are
wonderful and I
felt that it was a song that had a spiritual feel to it and was full of a sense of happiness.
What was the production process like for this song
?  I thought it was the first time that I had to make something like four songs for a song, and it was
so difficult for everyone but my friends to listen to it,
but I guess
that's why I was
able to create something without compromise.  I
think it's
the first song I've ever done, even though I really worked hard on it.Among the
members, I'm sure there are
people who were fans of the Jujutsu Kaisen manga and anime before they decided to provide the music, but if there were any, I'd say it's
my favorite.
Please tell me about the characters and scenes. I've
read Yurika-chan, right? I was
watching it. My
favorite characters and scenes are Maki and Amaki-senpai, all of whom wear
glasses and have ponytails,
but the
girl or that one is
really...  I like it. I feel like I
might be able to figure out anything. It's
amazing. I'm so
strong that I ca
n't lose to men. I'm
trying so hard that I can't even defeat a man. I
can't use gravity, it's not magic, but I somehow
make up for it. It's
like this physical ability elsewhere, so I
make up for it.  Well, that's the kind of
person who lives a great life and works really hard,
but in reality, he's really worried about his sister and his house.Is there a big scene
?Is there a big
scene?
When I heard about Jujutsu Kaisen, I
bought all the volumes of the manga, and
in the scene where the grasshopper case appears, I was struck by the idea that it was the humans who cursed the grasshoppers,
such as the environmental issues such as coexistence
with humans.  I felt
that there were various things that made me
think about the literature that I had seen, and some themes that made me think about culture and such things.The
Shibuya Incident is really good, thank you very much.The
Tale of the Heike, the hesitation of the immediate future, etc.  You
have also created music for other anime, but did you ever imagine that your
band would create music for anime?
Also, if there is an opportunity in the future,
would you like to continue providing music for anime?
What do you think?
But I hadn't
imagined it, so I
kind of thought I'd be part of a live-action movie or something.Also,
anime is amazing.There
are a lot of really cool songs that get your adrenaline pumping.
Since there are so many stores, I didn't
really imagine it at first, but when it comes to tie-up songs, I'm
working on the theme of balancing mainstream and underground, and balancing J-Pop and alter.  Well,
in terms of that aspect, I'm very particular about the sound creation and the tie-
up songs,
so both in terms of the music for Jujutsu
Kaisen and the
approach to the drums, I've
always used 4 notifications to
bring out a little bit of joy.  It was a
very good experience because I was able to create something new that helped me overcome my pain.
[Music] The
theme song and the opening theme for The Tale of the Heike and Immediate Hesitation made me
feel like I was creating a version of that work.
Even during the Heike era, it
was like playing the Tale of the Heike with a song, which was
really fun, but this time, there
was also an ending
[music] that
accompanied the work, and we were able to learn more about our own world.  I
was very conscious of trying to make things happen in this way, and it was
interesting that I was able to incorporate things that really represent who we are and things that I'm really interested in right now, and that I was able to really relate to the work as well.
It
means that you can take your time and work on things that you normally wouldn't be able to do, or things that you wouldn't have the courage to do, but I think it's
interesting to provide music for anime, so if I have the
chance, I'd like to do it again.  Do you
think the point of contact with your overseas fans was the new album released by Major Lesel and the charming online live show called Criterion Crais?
What does it mean to you to perform in front of an audience now?
So, is there a year in which you would like to perform live? I
couldn't perform live due to the coronavirus, but performing live
in front of an audience
feels like a live performance.
Well, what often comes up in the story is that the
audience in each city is
different.  We often
talk about how our performance changes depending on the audience.It's
true that this is unique to live performances, but on the
other hand, our audience was
very
quiet.During
Corona.  Up until that point, we didn't
really feel like we were in a band, and we never said things like, ``
Speak out loud,'' or ``
Have fun.'' There
was a certain kind of spirit about it, and that's why the
audience was so excited.  I think that's why I was listening to it because I was really nervous because I was so nervous with the audience, and
when I was quiet, I was moved. Maybe that's why I was listening to it because I was so moved by the quiet moments. I mean, with
or without this inside, it's probably us who are a
little more grown up and listening to the song.
Maybe it was the frustration of not being able to perform live inside the venue,
but
after we opened, I
realized how powerful the audience was, and they
gave me great voices.  I've experienced things like, "I'm putting out music because I want to
put it out," or "I'm
putting it out because I want to put out something, even if I don't have to say, 'I'm going to put out this.'" That's why I
think it's so powerful, and I'm able to perform while receiving cake.These days, I
want to perform live.  Is there a particular city? Yes,
there are a lot of bands that are influenced by the UK, so
I went to London the other day and it was really fun. I've never been to America either, so it's amazing. I want to
go to America, too.
That's why Canada.  It's been a long time since I
heard a live show overseas, but Yurika-chan didn't
really listen to it, so I think we all want to go together, and there
are many places in Asia that I haven't been to yet, and there are
so many wonderful things to do around the world, such as Sweet Love Shower and the upcoming Sweet Love Shower.  You have a private room at festivals,
but
what do you look forward to the most when performing normally?
[Laughs] It's
definitely food. It's amazing how you
explain things. I
don't understand Japanese festivals, but there
are so many amazing local foods.  I don't think
there are many festivals overseas where you can eat delicious food from various places.I've never
eaten food at a festival overseas
before.Japan
is already a paradise, where you can eat as much as you want and
drink local alcohol, things
like Fuji Rock.  Is it a little
different? I don't know, but the breakfast is very fulfilling.The
two of us are
like musicians, so it's
definitely something we're looking forward to.At
Fuji Rock, even the regular customers are
saying a lot.It's amazing how much we
enjoyed this year.What's the best part?
Shintaro Sakamoto
was great. I was really
moved by the real time. It was great.
Even though I was holed up in the dressing room, we
watched it together. I was able to see it for the
third time at Fuji Rock. Well, the
first time I saw it was when I was a college student, along with the
surgery.  Segalos is
amazing.It's an unforgettable experience.It's amazing.There's a
feeling of
euphoria, a feeling of floating, and a sense of euphoria.I
remember talking about idol cymbals and other cymbals.
[Music]
Yes, your music is
dark.  While you're dealing with subject matter and lyrics, I
feel like you also have rhythmic and emotional intelligence at the same time.
How do you balance the singer and the sound? Please
tell me more about your songwriting process.
I see.
Balance between sweets and sound
But sweets and sound
are always the same.
[Music]
There are new songs. The lyrics and lyrics of that song are really
dark, but
I've also gone in the direction of making the sound brighter and brighter. But I feel like I'm the singer in this song.  We're always
together, or rather, we're
together right now.If we play the way we feel, we'll end up together.There's a lot of
tension.I'm the one who
creates the song with the singer, and
at the beginning, we always
create it together.  Even if I don't have everything written, I ca
n't write a song unless I have something I want to say, so I
usually have a vision, and sometimes I'll
incorporate something that seems like it came before me,
but even if it's the exact opposite.
Even if the song and the lyrics are completely opposite, it
really starts like this,
so I have a vision,
so I guess I just create it while conveying it.Well, there are a lot of times these days when I don't even convey it, but I feel like I'm
saying little by little while I'm making it.Recently, it's been
like this.  I often arrange things in the studio,
arrange them in the rehearsal studio,
take them to the recording studio, and
fine-tune them.But
yes,
literature is a soccer scene.Do you
ever hear people talk about artists like Legally Chill Bains?  Have you ever
co-written or co-starred with someone?
Also, who are the artists who have influenced you the most?
That's right. I've collaborated with them, but I
haven't, but there are times when we go to festivals or something like that. I
wonder if I'm a little closer to them.  I do
n't know, I don't know, it's
cute, it's cute,
yeah,
we're close in age, I'm a little older, but we're close, I'm
a little older than you, but in terms of my
career, I think I'm a bit senior to you.That's
true.I really like it.I
like it.  You know,
when I came to Japan once, I
said I wanted to do it, and I
called it the opening, so we've performed together,
but I probably
won't remember it if I don't remember it,
but I really like them.There are still many artists who have influenced me the most.  I'm sure you'll be
doing a lot, but I guess
Yak
and
I
are the Stones, and I'm on
pixiv.
Yes, I want to be called in advance, so I'll put it in American
Football Shoegaze and US
Indie.
Indie Rock Collection, J-Pop
Emo, etc.
Pictures.  Do you fit
into a specific genre? Is there a particular genre you would like to
try? I'm
punk, or
alternative rock, or
psychedelic, ambient,
post-rock, or any number of other
genres in my
own way.  It's important to digest it independently and turn it
into a song, so
[music]
Yes, I think that's true.I think that
genre has elements.I don't want to give in, I do
n't want to be criticized, I don't
want to be criticized.It's a
feeling that is like a spiritual part.  So, I do
n't have a specific genre, but do you
have any goals or milestones that you have set for your future activities?I want to
perform a lot in Japan, but I
also want to
perform outside of Japan, and I also want to live outside of Japan.
That's why I think it
would be nice to be able to work anywhere if
something like that happens.So-san also thinks it would be nice to have something like "Shanghai Gathering Shanghai-san." Should we
make that our goal, or
record in London and then disband there.I
think that's interesting.  I saw Noboru Kuma at that Fuji Rock. It's
amazing how everyone plays various instruments,
and sometimes they don't listen, and the three of them
keep doing new things. I do
n't know, but
yes, it's the last minute. I'm looking forward to the
upcoming project album tour, etc.
Fans  Do you have any plans to look forward to?
But it would be great if we could perform a lot outside of Japan. I
hope we can go overseas next year. I'm thinking about it.
Yes. [
Music]
Yes. Please
answer in one word with one view for each person.
Please, the top artists on the playlist I'm listening to right now are
Worlds,
End Girl,
Paint Heap, and my favorite anime is
Neon Genesis Evangelion,
Doraemon in the 90s, Cyberpunk
Ecchi, and I don't even have a T-
shirt.I don't even have a
fake T-shirt.  I really
like it so much that I looked it up because I wanted it.The
song I often sing at fake karaoke is equivalent to
Perfume
[Music]
Chihiro Onizuka's
thing that gives me the most inspiration
[Music] I
love embroidery, right? I guess it's the word choice and
the sensibility.  I take great care of myself in that aspect,
so I find it interesting to
see how creatively I choose words, and it's really cool.
Well, I'm happy to introduce it to the fan club, so I guess it's
inspiration,
natural, right? I was
thinking about it.  Things that I didn't know about come to me like this, I
blend in with them beforehand, and I'm sure I'll write some songs, and sometimes I'll
sleep, so I'll support you, and then I'll be in a daze.I
wonder
who I am, friends, lovers, things like that.  I feel
inspired
or
energized by watching it.When we
eat together, I
get really energized.When I
write lyrics, I
feel like I'm the one who receives the stage the most, but it's about
my current situation and memories.
Lately, I've probably been thinking a lot about my relationship with music, and
sometimes movies.If I had to
describe Sheep Literature in one word, it would
be that it's both mainstream and underground. [Music] I see why it's
so protean.
Yes.  That's it
[Music]
[Music] I
'll point out the people who seem to fit the bill. The
members who are
the most likely to become magicians are the ones who are the most powerful.
Well,
that's right. Charisma.
To put it
more specifically, the next member I'd like to fight with in a magic battle is,
well, that's Se.
That's what I was
thinking.It's like a
double kick together.Oh, I see.Next, I also
have an image of him being the best at dancing.He looks good when he
dances.He has some
athletic nerves.When he
dances, he's
the most mischievous member.  That's
right.
[Music]
The members who don't share their food are the ones who do
n't share their food. [Music] [Laughter] The members who don't share their food. Isn't there a member who doesn't share their food
with them?
[Music]
Don't eat what you think they're sharing.
But what he likes to eat the most is
salmon,
because he really likes it,
and
the vegetables on the side.
[Laughs] The
member who tends to forget his own part is Seino.
[Music] No, no, no, no.
That
song and
[music]
I'm arranging it in terms of live arrangement rather than perfection. Sometimes I
suddenly
change my perfume, or it's
difficult because I sing in the chorus, etc.
[music] I'm not
good at memorizing things, but
thank you for making me think.  The
members who wake up late are
n't late. They're
really late. Their
activity times are different. I'm
sorry. Is Erika-chan
early when she's early?
Well, I took a nap at that time. Only one of us got
up at 5 o'clock and
started at 7 o'clock.  He woke up at 5 a.m. and went to the hot springs, so he's
amazing.
[Music] The members are discovering new
music.  I don't know
what I did with Deaf Sheep Literature, but I
want to do my best so that I can go to your town from now on. Please
enjoy the anime.
Thank you
[Music]